if i had a gun with two bullets and i
was in a room with hitler bin laden and
toby i would shoot toby twice
okay all right really funny and then you
went too far here is an old man and a
golf dude and then the old crone from
drag me to hell i'm a hobo i asked for a
list
and a clown
i'm jigsaw idiot you're not as scary as
a book face over there
yes i am the popular social networking
site known as bookface
okay kids you all have been so good and
unbelievably patient
so i think you are gonna get some candy
[Applause]
kids just remember suicide is never the
answer
all right why is christmas the only
holiday that can have a message
it is the easy way out you are not alone
what the hell is wrong with you
who wants candy
luke is going to use his laser pointer
to point to account setup you click on
that first then a whole new knot no no
no luke come on come on not on oscar's
head
all right luke come on stop it what i'm
stopping it that's what you said give me
the pointer so you just want me to move
it that's you're being totally unclear
here i'm just gonna go ahead and move it
no just power it down no no no no no not
on angela's poop come on come on luke
seriously all right fine fine i'll just
go okay i'm going all right
okay
good job
okay email accounts so we're starting
with the count setup oh my god is it in
my eyeball yeah i think he's burning my
eye michael do something shack up you
have to stop this luke can i have that
no okay i am going to count down from
five
five
four
i'm not kidding
three
two two
one
[Music]
what the hell was that i had to do that
scroll it all right are we good
there's somebody i'd like you to meet
somebody else
who has been to prison
who can tell you what it is
really like
i'm prison mike
you know why they call me prison mike do
you really expect us to believe you're
somebody else do you really expect me to
not push you up against the wall [ __ ]
all right hey hey hey that's just the
way we talk in the clink but a lot of
fun talk about prison today but i am
here to scare you straight
i am in this game
in prison you are somebody's [ __ ]
oh and you you my friend would be the
bell of the ball don't drop the soap
don't drop the soap michael please
so what do you think it doesn't sound so
great does it
wow
thank you
um that must been hard for you to relive
that
both of you
yeah that
wasn't really
at all my experience
there's certain elements of what you've
performed i i've seen on television
but it didn't remind me of my time in
prison
okay okay fine
you guys think prison is so great all
right
well
here you go
okay michael come on let us out no if
you think prison is so wonderful then
enjoy prison
they are such
babies i am going to leave them in there
until they can appreciate what it's like
to have freedom
and if this doesn't bother them then i'm
out of ideas
hey
hey um 63.50 and that's not including
two right i have the coupon so half of
63.50 and half the tip on 63.50 half off
coupons only applied orders of two
pizzas yeah no i told them on the phone
i was ordering egg pizzas
i don't care you told them on the phone
that's her policy
you didn't actually think that i was
gonna spend 60 bucks on pizza it's not
pizza okay it doesn't say it anywhere on
the coupon and if it's your policy you
should say it on the coupon
what do you mean
not my problem it is your problem
that's the way to do business
okay i
ordered
eight pizzas with a half off coupon so i
would like eight pizzas for half off end
of story it's a great story it's 63.50
and that's not including tip i'm not
giving that to you well then you're not
getting your pizza no
no you're not no you are not going
anywhere you're going to stay here until
we figure this out
what you know what this young man needs
to learn that that's not how you treat
people
i don't care if it's pizza good business
is about respect and accountability and
follow-through you don't just make
promises and pull the rug out from under
somebody do you dwight please escort
this young man into the conference room
right now get in the conference i'm not
going in yeah you are yeah you are and
you will come out when you decide to
give me a discount on the pizza please
thank you
oh this is stupid yo you don't even know
what stupid is
it's about to get all stupid up in here
if anyone out there is listening i'm
being held here against my will
i'm a minor so if you'd all raise your
glasses not pam for obvious reasons but
everyone else if you would raise your
glasses what's obvious why can't pam
drink
pam can't drink who i didn't i shouldn't
have said that i don't know why i did
she can do whatever she wants
though she shouldn't
she shouldn't because she's an alcoholic
pam is an alcoholic yeah that's not true
i no the
what we wanted the real the real reason
is that um
the pam's pregnant um
okay okay okay hey
what i think jim is trying to say is
that
they had an accident and you know what
these two people they're living together
they are having lots of consensual sex
they were living together yes yes they
were living yes and you know what you
can't
expect them to be careful every time
because frankly it's just a different
sensation michael when you come well am
i wrong they say it's not different but
it's a different sensation oh my god
when you use
something to block
yeah i think everybody knows what i am
talking about it's not necessarily
different for the woman
but it is different okay okay okay
michael for the stop all right
my point is
i said what i wanted to say and mima i
hope you heard every word
what is this
that is my christmas card
it's a picture of you and me and your
kids on a ski trip having a blast skis
and greetings no see
we never went on a ski trip i know i
don't i went on a ski trip right two
years ago with my kids and my ex-husband
yes but what you didn't realize at the
time was that i was with you in a sense
i was in your heart
and next to your kids what this is
so weird
i don't understand get in on this hey
it's cool man i work in the warehouse
i'm cool
i'm hip and i'm jive but i don't care
about nobody do you know who i am
happy halloween jerk still don't know
who i am i'll give you a hint
i go over other people's heads michael
this is a bad idea what's a bad idea
dressing up as somebody i mean when has
that ever worked for you
behold
jesus christ
you